some kind of dark side what do you want
I'd forgotten that may the fifth was
coming up I threw this together
[Applause]
[Music]
that's half true I I had been planning
to revisit a ranking of these Star Wars
movies now that rise of Skywalker not
only is out but I've had enough distance
from it that I can you know just think
about it and not have to worry
excessively about I'm too close to its
point of release so oh god this is two
ranked videos in a row
it's that tacky might be tacky heck with
it okay so let's talk about all 11 Star
Wars films I'm not counting the Ewok
films because been so long since I saw
them to assess them fairly I have to
rewash them I ain't doing that number 11
Episode one The Phantom Menace here's
the thing about this and I honestly kind
of struggled with whether or not I
wanted to put this at the bottom because
there are things I like about it I
genuinely love the Darth Maul lightsaber
fight I think that the podrace is pretty
good I think that your McGregor is solid
in it but the things that are bad are so
atrociously bad basically hinging on two
things
there's the midi-chlorians which
honestly I'm not as ticked about as I
used to be don't get me wrong it's
massively horrific Lee stupid but it
doesn't actually affect too much about
the story going on it's just it's
dropped in because George was decided to
do it but what drives me crazy more than
anything more than Jar Jar Binks its
Anakin why the heck is he nine years old
why isn't he 13 14 and an age where a
line like I've been a pilot my whole
life has any meaning whatsoever when a
nine-year-old says is like oh that's
cute I'm supposed to take you seriously
know things at the bottom I can't watch
this anymore
number 10
episode 2 Attack of the Clones there's
nothing in this that's as bad as what is
bad about star wars episode 1 but there
isn't a lot that's great about it either
I have more things that I'm like oh yeah
that bit in episode 1 that I do in
episode 2 there's almost nothing in
episode 2 that is particularly memorable
it just doesn't hit the lows as hard I
don't I guess that's a mild improvement
although I'm not gonna be applying that
consistently there were some other close
calls here where it was between a film
that either had more mediocrity or more
wildly varying things that I felt about
it depending on the part of the film and
I'm not gonna do it the same way each
time but in this case I'm gonna put it
slightly above episode 1 just because
the things that have very 8 me about
episode 1 they infuriate me so much to
the point that I can't even watch it
episode 2 it's not that I feel like I
would get angry if I tried to watch it
again I just get bored number 9 solo
there's another case where I would
largely just be bored it's not even that
bad a film it tries to do way way way
too much it basically takes every single
known fact about Han Solo and crammed it
into his first adventure ever where he's
meeting Chewie meeting Lando getting the
Falcon doing the Kessel run and by the
end of it setting himself up with Jabba
like really it's that that that was just
dumb it should have been like any one of
those things it should not have been all
those things that said performances are
pretty good chemistry between Han and
Chewie is solid that works the actions
decent it's pretty well shot there's
again not a lot in the way particular
highs it's fine it's functional it gets
the job done that's about all I've got
number eight the rise of Skywalker
Episode nine I really didn't know where
I was gonna put this and if you'd watch
my review of that you might have thought
it would have been higher than this or
at the very least
above the last Jedi because coming out
of it I was happier with the viewing
experience of it that I was a little
last Jedi and that was absolutely true
but the more I think about it it's just
such a jumbled chaotic mess of a movie
you can tell that this was something
that was thrown together very hastily to
meet a release date that there were old
scrapped plans you can feel the process
you can feel that somebody was brought
in at the last minute to take over this
the plot is pulled out of its butt and
as they've released more stuff to try
and cover up the plot holes my immediate
thought has always been why wasn't that
just in the movie there's still a few
good things in here mostly having to do
with kylo Ren who I will still cite as
the MVP of the new trilogy I found him
the most consistently fascinating
character in each entry and I found his
arc here to be really good I thought his
bond with Rey was very good there was
some cool moments there was some good
banter I liked the the planet-hopping in
a bit of the treasure hunt that was kind
of fun but oh my god the Emperor and the
climaxes thing is aa ridiculous read
like fan fiction number seven episode
eight the last Jedi yeah so I did put it
above rise of Skywalker but not by much
so I'll just reiterate quickly the
problems I have with this thing are not
the ones that the loudest detractors of
this movie have I don't think that Rey
being nobody is a problem I actually
think that was one of the best moves
that this movie made and it's one of the
things that I really disliked about
episode 9 was undoing that so I thought
it was one of the few really solid
decisions this film make so it's a
deconstruction but it's a deconstruction
using the characters as opposed to doing
an alternate universe doing surrogates
for the characters and when you
deconstruct something you break it and
in some cases that just annoyed people
that bugged me a little to some
but on the whole it just is it doesn't
make sense
I don't mean logistically I mean
thematically and I mean flow and
construction especially in terms of a
trilogy and it's so evident now that
these films were not fully planned but
they were presenting them as if they
were and this felt so disconnected from
the previous one and even as a film unto
itself
it has sections that do not need to be
there characters that don't have a heck
of a lot of function and some of the
things that get tied up get tied up in a
way it's like well what was even the
point of that number six Episode three
Revenge of the Sith I have a soft spot
for this one it's the one prequel film
that I will actually watch for pleasure
there's still some awkward notes in it
some of the character beats are they're
just not written with very much elegance
and the actors are doing the best I can
with them but I like the overall
trajectory of the characters some of the
story beats I think are really solid
some of the moments I think are
incredibly well done the execution of
order 66 is phenomenally done that I
remember that choked me up for some I
saw it in the theater and there's a lot
of good here but it is way down in a lot
of the baggage of a script that is
clunky and actors who don't know how to
deliver this kind of dialogue and an
over-reliance on CGI but I will tell you
that last lightsaber fight I give it
props because it carries a lot of
emotional weight and that is down to
some solid performances I do enjoy this
film number 5 episode 7 the force
awakens yeah I do still like this even
though everything came apart
after this I do still actually enjoy
this as a film unto itself there are
bits that are a little less fun now all
the sequel baiting that is in this but
as a story unto itself I still like it I
like the vibe I think this is a very
good job of recapturing the feel
of the original Star Wars films that's
what I wanted from this film that's what
I got from this film it just works for
me number four
rogue one front half of this thing is a
little bit clunky you can feel the the
hands on it you can see the stitches
because the flow for the front half is
very janky and it doesn't have a great
transition from scene to scene setting
to setting character beat to character
beat it just kind of chugs along for a
bit but once they get on that planet for
their actual mission at the end once
that starts through to the end wow I
love it I love most of these characters
I find them really fun and enjoyable and
endearing and just really I enjoy having
them around there's obviously the Darth
Vader stuff but that was icing on the
cake even before that I really liked
this movie I liked that they had the
guts to kill everybody which was what
that was the thing that I was so
convinced they wouldn't do it I would be
leaving going they should have killed
everyone but they didn't have the guts
to do it but they did it and that's how
it should have ended it gets off to a
rocky start but once it gets a head of
steam this thing just cooks now this
does mean that huge shock
top-3 is the original three films big
surprise they're what I grew up on
nostalgia is powerful let's do it
number three Return of the Jedi I think
the only complaints I have about this
are complaints that I am looking at it
with an adult eye the first act is very
disconnected from the regular all the
stuff at Jabba's palace while it's very
cool from any sort of structural story
standpoint like that's that is a
completely detached things it's like
it's like a super extra long pre credit
sequence from a Bond film but it's just
fun and you know things like the Ewoks
yeah maybe they were a little bit too
cutesy but I'm kind of okay with them
and again maybe that's not al-jabat I
can as an
dolt with a better knowledge of story
structure and how things layout to be
you know more efficient and for best
flow I can see flaws in this that as a
kid I wouldn't have even known to look
for that doesn't do a lot to diminish my
enjoyment of the film but it does mean
that it brings it down a little bit
lower
that last lightsaber fight between Darth
Vader and Luke though that's my favorite
lightsaber fight of this entire
franchise I gotta put that out there
number two the Empire Strikes Back I
would say this is actually probably the
best film and the franchise from a
filmmaking nuts and bolts script
Direction acting most objective measures
stand points
this is the best made film it's not my
favorite but it is phenomenally well
made it is such a wonderful next step
from what happened before it's scales it
both mages to scale up the threat while
also making the threat more personal
when it comes to what's going on with
Luke and Darth Vader it manages to do
both at the same time and that is no
small thing
that plus all these wonderful new
locations terrifically bizarre character
is an excellent lightsaber duel you know
that's inventive and in a way that that
first one with with obi-wan and the and
a new hope just wasn't buddy it is such
a perfect escalation from the film that
is my actual favorite number one a new
hope I can't justify this for anything
other than nostalgia what I can tell you
though is when I was a kid and I would
play Star Wars when I would pretend I
was always pretending parts of this film
it was the infiltration of the Death
Star or it was the trench run or it was
Luke and Han blasting the TIE fighters
in the melon
Falkon this was always the one that
connected with my inner child the best
or when I was actually child just me as
a kid and it's one that's stuck with my
inner child ever since and since these
are part of my childhood and I love them
as that I'm not sure necessarily first
and foremost but very heavily the one
that still speaks the loudest to my
child my inner child yeah I have to give
the other number one spot I can't not
that's my ranking for these films what's
yours
whatever it is drop it on down in the
comments leave your thoughts on mine or
whatever else you want to do there's
links subscribe like share this around
consider supporting me on patreon
perhaps whatever you feel like doing no
pressure though I'm not gonna tell you
what to do end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned you will like share and
subscribe sorry have to try
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]